Ayer se completó el primero de los cuatro parones de selecciones de esta temporada,
que debe llevarnos evidentemente a una Copa del Mundo que arranca en nueve meses.
Queda bastante todavía, pero ya estamos en temporada de Mundial y sabemos lo que condiciona
eso a futbolistas, entrenadores, equipos, etc.
Es el momento perfecto para inaugurar una nueva sección aquí en la pizarra de Quintana,
el Power Ranking del Mundial 2026, con el que vamos a ordenar parón a parón a nuestras
diez grandes favoritas de cara al Mundial.
Ya hacemos en nuestro canal de YouTube, en Pizarritas, un Power Ranking del Fútbol Europeo.
Aquí medimos resultados, por supuesto, pero vamos un poquito más allá.
Niveles, sensaciones de cara al Mundial, a sabiendas de que todavía hay muchas selecciones
que no están clasificadas.
Pero bueno, vamos haciendo ya nuestra quiniela.
Sí, y quizá este primero tenga alguna sorpresita.
¿Tú crees?
No sé, yo creo que hay alguna selección ahora que la gente igual no espera.
A mí hay una selección que creo que está baja, que la vi ayer, llevaba tiempo sin verla
y me gustó.
Yo estoy contento con el top 10 que nos ha salido.
Yo creo que hay una selección que no debería estar.
Vale.
Vamos ya con el ranking porque estamos sin mucho tiempo, no nos vamos a meter a la sección
clasificada, ya le iremos comentando y ya lo iremos actualizando parón a parón.
No estaba lo de Cabo Verde tampoco en la escaleta ahí, me lo acabas de soltar.
Es que nos ha clasificado Cabo Verde.
Tarjeta amarilla, tarjeta amarilla.
Vamos con el ranking.
En décima posición hemos querido situar a una selección que no tiene una buena racha,
pero que antes de la Copa América pintaba realmente bien.
Yo sigo creyendo que es una de las 10 favoritas a ganar el Mundial.
Es la selección uruguaya.
No, no, no debería estar.
Es imposible que gane Uruguay en Mundial.
Pero más allá del contra agafe.
Es imposible.
Pero en el ranking.
No puede estar, no puede ganar Uruguay.
Pero más allá del contra agafe.
No puede estar.
¿Está mal Uruguay?
¿Tú es la que no querías que estuviera?
No, no, es que de hecho, candidata clara a la primera ronda fuera.
Es lo que viene pasando últimamente, ¿pero crees que va a volver a pasar?
Eso es mentira, pero yo creo que ya está, no ya está, se acaba Uruguay.
Vale, voy a ir al fútbol entonces, de Giano, Nau, o sea, Adri.
Yo tengo una sensación con la selección uruguaya que es, creo que por las imágenes
que hemos podido ver de la celebración de la clasificación, se han limado las perezas
entre cuerpo técnico y grupo, que eso parecía bastante relevante.
Parecía un poco guerra civil, acordáos en el primer parón de 2024.
En definitiva, parecía que se iban a complicar mucho las cosas.
Ha ganado tres partidos desde la Copa América, eso sí que es verdad.
Ha conseguido la clasificación un poco… ¿Tres de cuántos?
De 12.
Le ha faltado media convocatoria.
Y en 2025 ha ganado dos partidos, ha empatado dos y ha perdido dos.
O sea, ha hecho todo perfecto.
Para mí, sensaciones que creo que pueden ir a mejor.
Una vez ya se ha pasado ese proceso de clasificación…
Te liberas.
… y que creo que es una selección que puede llegar bien.
Ahora bien.
No me parece que tampoco tenga un jugador individual que le alce.
A mí es la selección que más me… Evidentemente, por eso está décima.
Aquí podía notar diferentes selecciones, pero yo sigo creyendo.
Es que me gustó mucho Uruguay antes de la Copa América.
Esos partidos contra Brasil, contra Argentina.
Luego es Uruguay, tiene esa tradición, hay que ganarla.
Bueno, yo creo que tiene que estar aquí, pero no.
Con muchos equipos.
Quiero creer en esta selección uruguaya, pero creo que si a alguien le sienta bien,
llegar fuera de este power ranking al Mundial, es la selección uruguaya.
También te digo, está décima.
Bueno, bueno, pero que igual el Nadal Mirandas ha descrémado el 15º puesto.
No, no, no.
A lo Bajini.
No creo que…
Acedo al verde en el flyer, no, no.
A lo Bajini.
En novena posición…
Si arruinan a la navia, es que no puede ser…
En novena posición tenemos a Marruecos.
Una selección que no aparece en la mayoría de… Nos hemos ido a ver casas de apuestas,
pronósticos también por… Oye, bichear y hacernos honerar de cómo ven las cosas,
no ya en España, sino en Inglaterra, en Francia…
En Estados Unidos con el tema del…
Exactamente.
Marruecos no suele estar en el top 10.
Y es verdad que su nivel y su participación en el pasado Mundial tuvo parte de Noticiablo
y de Sorpresa.
Pero yo creo que luego su rendimiento no fue casual, creo que ha ido acumulando noticias
positivas, creo que también es un colectivo super competitivo y creo que sin lugar a dudas
ahora mismo es la mejor selección africana a pesar de que no hiciese una gran Copa África.
No, no hicieron una gran Copa África, eliminaron Sudáfrica de hecho.
Estuve viendo ayer precisamente la inauguración del nuevo estadio y demás, ese Marruecos-Níger
y me encantó la selección marroquí.
Laterales abiertos, tiene un lateral izquierdo que es nuevo, que tiene Ben…
Belambani.
Belambani ese.
Muy abiertos, luego por dentro junta muchísimo talento, es Sofiano Amrabat el pivote y a
partir de ahí Ben Seguir, Brahim, el Villalcan…
No, él tiene seguramente al mejor jugador que es madrileño, pero evidentemente jugaba
con Marruecos, el mejor jugador africano, que es Arraja Kimi.
Sí, Arraja Kimi, que juega muy abierto pero tiene libertad.
Es verdad que está en una posición quizás no tan determinante, pero es que hemos visto
a Raph ser determinante desde esa posición.
Hay un chaval afincado en Liverpool que tendría algo que decir a este respecto.
Sí, pero quizá por formalizar.
No está en el power ranking, pero…
Egipto se pudo clasificar ayer y el punto cero.
Creo que… es que estaba pensando yo en el balón de oro sobre todo, creo que van a estar
en una posición similar, pero sí, Mohamed Salah evidentemente está ahí.
Ibarri, por ejemplo, ha nacido en Tarragas…
Muy bueno.
Metió dos goles contra Níger de nueve prácticamente y una selección que para mí tiene muchísimos
recursos para hacer un gran mundial.
Está Bonu, que lo vimos en el Mundial de Clubes, que fue una fortaleza.
Sabemos que el estilo de Marruecos es el que es.
Lo sabemos por desgracia, además.
Sí, sí.
Lo sufrimos en nuestras carnes.
Yo creo que esta es la selección que le va a sorprender a la gente, que aparezca Marruecos
en esta clasificación de las 10 favoritas, que aparezca como novena, pero claro, uno
repasa la fase de clasificación y se la está dominando por completo.
Son 21 puntos.
El finalista del pasado mundial también.
Siete victorias.
21 goles, por favor.
Dos en total.
Ha cambiado mucho y les ha cambiado para mal, yo creo, a los grandes jugadores de esa generación.
Aunque vete tú a saber si como en ese mundial que rindieron como nadie, porque esto nos
lo dice siempre Alberto Diogo y a poco que repases…
Que ya no es fútbol, es casi cultura, ¿no?
O social, sí.
O sociopolítica, no sé cómo llamarlo.
El sentimiento del aficionado marroquí, del futbolista marroquí es súper potente.
Brutal.
Mientras muchos jugadores nacidos en Europa, pero de ascendencia y origen africano decían
jugar con selecciones europeas, Marruecos retiene casi todo su talento.
Por suerte se le ha escapado el mejor.
Bueno, mira…
Que podía haber jugado ahí, que es la mía mal.
Sí.
Pero la mayoría de futbolistas afectan jugar con Marruecos por delante de Francia, Bélgica…
Marruecos tiene dos laterales de derecho nacidos en España.
O sea, que son Arraza y Omar Gimárez.
Y que Arraza no dijimos.
No, bueno, el rollo Brahim.
No, bueno…
No, no, no.
Arraza lo quería del fútbol español y Arraza quiso jugar con Marruecos.
Estoy hablando de memoria, pero de las 32 selecciones que jugaban en 2022, creo que
Marruecos era la selección que tenía más futbolistas nacidos fuera del territorio marroquí.
Y te decía eso porque tienen un punto competitivo que a mí me recuerda a lo sudamericano.
El sentimiento ese…
No sé si nacionalista o de jugar algo más que fútbol que sacó lo mejor de Anrabat,
de Amalai, de Aunaji porque desde entonces ninguno ha estado de todos.
Y un detalle muy importante con las selecciones africanas.
Hay Copa de África justo antes de Mundial.
O sea, en el período diciembre-tenero hay Copa de África.
Eso es tremendo.
O sea, hay que tener…
Es tremendo y es negativo.
Bueno, se han desplazado por motivos obvios.
Sí, sí, sí.
En octava posición a mí me sorprende ver también tan lejos del top 3, podríamos decir.
Pero ha bajado posiciones en este parón.
Es Alemania, Adri.
El toque de atención de Nagelsmann, los silbidos y abucheos el otro día ante Irlanda del Norte.
Las sensaciones que está transmitiendo una selección que se puede ir a la repesca perfectamente.
Uf.
La retirada de Kroos, la adhesión de Musiala.
Son muchos factores los que están…
Yo creo que Alemania va a subir posiciones según vayamos haciendo este powerranken de
aquí a junio.
Pero ahora creo que tiene que estar aquí.
El momento de Antonio Rüdiger.
Son muchos factores que invitan a no ser optimistas con Alemania ahora mismo.
Y yo creo que el tirón de orejas del otro día de Nagelsmann, público apuntando directamente
a la plantilla.
Es un mensaje de alarma importante porque él es el primero que huele, el primero que detecta
que como si ganase las cosas, puede haber batacazo Alemania en el Mundial.
En los últimos cinco partidos, una victoria, un empate, tres derrotas.
Las malas sensaciones que acumula.
Yo el partido de Irlanda del Norte lo estuve viendo y…
Es que me daba una sensación de que el equipo no avanzaba.
Que se organizaban tres centrales con carrileros, sobre todo el de la derecha más largo que
era Lebelin, el futbolista este tan interesante del Stuttgart.
Y muchos problemas para organizar el juego.
Kimmich y Pascall Gross no terminan de cuajar del todo.
Me dejó algo de dudas.
De hecho, la medida de puntos empieza a parecerse mucho a la de la era Flick, que fue una era
también muy complicada.
Flick no se pudo llevar al 22 a Florian Birch, que estaba recuperado pero recién recuperado.
Da la sensación de que el escenario con Musiala va a ser similar.
Que va a llegar sano con la de la alta médica.
Pero el postito.
Y bueno, tiene que cambiar mucho la situación en Alemania porque salvo que Angelos Thieler
dé un paso adelante muy bestia, en el centro del campo creo que va a ir muy coja.
Y lo del lateral derecho es que desde la retirada de Philipp Lange no termina de encontrar una
alternativa.
Es que te iba a decir, Alex, que de hecho ese partido que mencionabas de Alemania le ha
hecho en el ranking que nosotros íbamos proyectando perder una posición respecto a la séptima
clasificada que nosotros situamos que es Países Bajos.
Países Bajos tampoco va…
Países Bajos no va sobradísima.
A lo bajiri.
Va un poquito así.
Tampoco tiene ninguna participación super destacada en los últimos años.
No.
Pero creo que es una selección que es estable.
¿Es de las máximas favoritas?
No.
Pero creo que es lógica esa última posición.
El Mundial elimina a Argentina en ese partido llevado hasta la tanda de penaltis.
Ya pasa.
Que mira, bobo.
Y en la Eurocopa, bueno, yo creo que intentó algo más.
Sobre todo con esta generación joven, Berger Brugge en portería, etcétera, etcétera,
pero es un equipo que para mí sigue teniendo un problema bastante importante y es que el
gol se sigue centrando en la figura de Memphis.
Máximo goleador ya histórico.
Es verdad que Rangers está creciendo.
Es verdad que en estos torneos GACPOO se crece.
Bueno, y Dan Frisby te cuento que es verdad que viene de una gran Champions pero Dan Frisby
es el jugador de selección por excelencia.
Totalmente.
Que luego se crece mucho.
De GACPOO contaban antes el Mundial del 22, que parece que lo podía hacer el Southampton,
después del Mundial Liverpool.
Y es verdad que le está costando en según qué posiciones hacer el relevo generacional.
Creo que hay posiciones que quizás se están atascando un poco.
En las centrales van bien, por ejemplo.
Pero no es una selección que enamore, pero oye, está ahí.
Yo creo que el suelo lo está marcando.
En ese nivel medio alto, sexta posición.
A ver, se pone serio esto ya, eh.
Sí, aunque todavía no ha mejorado considerablemente.
Las apuestas le dan el segundo máximo favorito.
Confiarán mucho en Ancelotti.
Brasil.
Yo creo que las apuestas al final no dejan de ser pronósticos de la gente.
La casa de apuestas marca una cuota viendo lo que hay, pero luego el mercado sube y baja.
Un poco rollo bolsa según la confianza que tenga el aficionado.
Yo creo que es Brasil.
Que se le sitúa a Brasil porque es Brasil.
Más que por Ancelotti.
Ha tocado cosas.
Ganó el otro día.
A mí me gustó el partido.
El de Bolivia.
No lo he visto.
Y bueno, era un partido que no contaba, pero es una derrota de Brasil.
Y hay muchas dudas porque quién es el crack.
Los laterales.
El tema de los laterales.
La sensación además que como todo equipo grande carga con una losa de expectativas
o incluso favoritismo, insisto, segundo máximo favorito, que no es coherente con lo que viene
demostrando y eso es esa losa.
O sea, igual que Naguay se quería quitar el STD con Uruguay, Brasil no se lo puede quitar.
Y no tiene tanto talento como para llevar esa bitola de segundo favorito.
Tal y verdad que por las circunstancias Ancelotti no ha podido contar con todos los futbolistas
que entendemos.
Ha llevado una lista un poco alternativa.
No los ha podido juntar todavía todos.
No sabemos muy bien qué pretende Ancelotti con los cracks.
Y que mucho tiempo no tiene.
De la selección.
También es cierto.
Me gustó por ejemplo el partidante de Chile.
A mí me gustó mucho yo a Pedro.
Juegando con nueve.
Me gustó mucho el futbolista del Chelsea.
Y justo me parece una noticia importante para el nueve de la selección.
A mí me falta un nueve más mandón en el área.
Quizá.
O sea que le pueda solimentar más partidos.
Es verdad que va a ir Brasil un poco a que sean los extremos los que me lo resuelvan.
La llegada desde atrás que tiene unos llegadores.
Rafael está jugando a media punta.
Claro, pero sí.
O sea, yo tengo un poco de dudas y hay una cosa en Brasil a la que se agarran.
A Casemiro.
No.
Casemiro es más de agarrada.
¿Cuál es el último mundial que ganó Brasil?
Sí, evidentemente.
2002.
Pues esta es la pregunta.
Evidentemente.
Me ha encantado.
El que lo vi fue yo.
Que vosotros eras un hormíco.
Bueno, yo lo recuerdo perfectamente en Antena 3, comentado por Vicente del Bosque.
Por cierto, que lo da en vía digital y Antena 3, los partidos.
Eh…
Toma ya.
Ahora vas y lo cascas.
El dato que necesitabas.
La peor eliminatoria de Brasil ha sido esta.
Pero la que tuvieron más derrotas también fue en la previa 2002.
Se agarran un poco a olla.
A ver si apretamos un poco los machos y nos da.
A ver, Ronaldo Nazario, dónde estás.
Y Rivaldo.
La selección de 2002 partía de muy abajo.
Y no convencía nadie.
La de 2010 con Dunga era un horror.
Y bueno, si no se le va la cabeza a Felipe Melo, estamos hablando de semifinales.
La de 2014 era otro horror.
Y hace semifinales.
Y bueno, y le mete el 7 porque también se queda Santiago Silve sin Neymar.
Siempre tiene que agarrarse.
Sí, sí, sí.
Y por eso la situamos esta.
Porque si fuera por la comparativa con Uruguay, los últimos tres partidos no podría estar
ahí.
Por ejemplo.
Pero…
Pero Uruguay no debería estar en el top 10.
No, no, no.
Uruguay…
Y en Brasil tampoco.
Yo no la meto en el top 40, Uruguay.
Hombre, es estrictamente equivocado eso.
Bueno, si atendemos a la población que tiene las participaciones en el mundial, no entra
en el top 40.
Entonces…
No se le podría exigir a Uruguay que esté en el top 40.
Espera, que puede ir Surinam y Cabo Verde.
Vamos con el top 5.
A ver.
Yo creo que el top 5 es el potente de verdad.
Aquí ya veo un escalón de diferencia significativo que se puede acortar.
Pero hemos tenido claras las cinco primeras selecciones.
Yo había planteado un cambio de la selección de 2020.
Yo había planteado un cambio entre la quinta y la cuarta.
Al final no lo hemos hecho.
En quinta posición, Inglaterra.
Esa selección que todavía no ha dado el siguiente paso, esa selección que no es ganadora,
no es ganadora, pero que está jugando bien, que tiene mucho talento, tiene un nuevo seleccionador
que nos creemos mucho.
Yo a Inglaterra ahora mismo la situaría a cuarta.
Hay una cosa de tú, Gel, que me está gustando un poquito.
Que es, está sentando al equipo desde atrás.
Creo que es una cosa que a Inglaterra se le estaba resistiendo.
Inglaterra al final tiene potencial ofensivo a raudales.
Tiene a Harry Kane, a Bukayo Saka, a jugadores que le pueden solventar partidos.
Los que queráis.
Dos datines, si me dejas un momento.
Tomas tu gelabanado.
¿Te lo vas sentando desde atrás?
¿Qué es decir?
¿Saugrid también?
El problema de Saugrid es que era un equipo rígido de narices.
Pero una cosa es construir desde atrás un equipo que sea fiable a nivel defensivo.
Y otra cosa es ser un equipo que parte desde atrás.
A mí no me parece que tú Gel esté partiendo desde atrás.
No veo la diferencia.
No veo la diferencia importante.
Tú puedes construir un equipo siendo encerrado.
Y otra cosa es un equipo que se comporte bien a nivel defensivo.
Y sea capaz de solver...
Yo creo que la gran diferencia es que parte de una premisa parecía y tú Gel se va a hacer eso.
Puede ser. Puede estar ahí.
No ha encajado ningún gol tú Gel como seleccionador inglés.
Ese es el primer seleccionador inglés que en sus primeros cinco partidos los ha ganado todos.
Y además solo le han hecho un remate a puerta que fue Letonia.
En partidos oficiales.
Me refiero porque tienen ese amistoso antes Senegal que Palma.
Yo tengo dudas un poco de cómo es ese comportamiento ya en campo rival.
Todavía veo cosas...
Todavía veo cosas que no...
En medio de Andorra, por ejemplo, en Barcelona, que lo pude ver con mis ojos...
Fue muy duro.
Para mí es la duda porque es lo que está por resolverse.
Lo que sí que es verdad es que tú Gel ha conseguido...
Organizar equipos desde lo posicional muy positivo.
Tienen los futbolistas para eso.
Igual Inglaterra tiene otra cosa.
Pero lo de Sao Benz ya sí que parecía que estaba atascado.
Y mira que soy de los que valoro su trabajo.
Pero creo que el equipo para dar el siguiente nivel...
Necesitaba un entrenador del siguiente nivel.
Sí, también te digo que en torneos cortos de selecciones...
Sabemos que funciona esto de llegar a una selección...
Asumir poquitos riesgos.
De mínimos.
No encajar goles.
Entonces esto sí que funciona.
De Sao lleva 14 años.
Y tú Gel con algo más de margen, en otro contexto, lo hizo con su Chelsea.
Sí, pero es que es un poco su Chelsea.
O es un buenísimo error.
Pero mi duda es que yo veo a los de arriba de Inglaterra...
Y no veo ni la velocidad y autosuficiencia de Francia...
Que citabais desde Sao Benz.
Ni al perfil de futbolista que tenía ese Chelsea.
Veo un equipo que agradecería juntarse en torno a la pelota...
Y con tanta rigidez y inflexibilidad.
Que es lo que caracterizaba Sao.
Acordas de Foden pegadas a la banda izquierda.
Le habría encantado a ese Chelsea contar con Noni Madueke...
Que es, según los compañeros de Okta...
El primer futbolista de la selección Inglaterra desde el año 97...
En marcar y tener en su nombre todas las vocales.
Y fue su primer gol con Inglaterra, por cierto.
Y una cosa, simplemente.
Albania, Letonia, Andorra y Serbia han sido los rivales de la Inglaterra de tú Gel.
Nivel medio superior a Sudamérica.
Hay que tenerlo también en cuenta.
Bolivia está prácticamente clasificada perdiendo de partido.
Prácticamente.
Cuarta clasificada en nuestro powerrank en aquén.
Yo pondría quien, te insisto.
Francia.
Talento ya lo sabemos.
Y siempre está ahí y hay que ganarla.
Y nos costó en semifinal de Eurocopa.
Pero ver los partidos y todavía...
No sé.
A mí el de Ucrania me gustó.
Es que el de Islandia...
Ucrania que posteriormente ha empatado a uno contra la Zerbaian.
Bueno, pero hay que medir a los rivales.
No me puedo inventar el partido.
Pero me gustó.
La primera parte de Francia me gustó.
Yendo arriba, teniendo la pelota.
A mí el conecho a Mení...
Conecho a Mení suena a Pogba Kante.
Es verdad que contra Islandia no puede contar con Dembelen y con Douai.
Eso es verdad.
Le sobra polvo arriba, en Bapesta, finísimo.
En las descargas, en los apoyos, en los dos marques...
El tema es ver si con eso le va a dar.
Francia, Nahuel, parece una foto fija.
Cambian a algunos futbolistas, evolucionan otros tantos.
Cambian a los rivales.
Pero la Francia de Samp sigue ahí.
En lo positivo y en lo no tan positivo.
Es cierto que a raíz de la crítica que hace Samp
contra sus propios jugadores después de la final del 22,
70 minutos de partido.
Hay 7 o 8 que los habría cambiado.
Creo que se han puesto...
Las peores finales disputadas al menos de inicio.
Luego aparece Mbappé y cambia un poquito la historia.
Se ha girado un poquito el disparo.
Había mucho miedo al relevo de Griezmann, que hace un mundial tremendo.
Creo que ese problema lo ha solventado.
Con Olise.
Yo creo que sí.
Es buenísimo.
Pero que no reciba dentro del área.
El lío del otro día.
Hay muchos futbolistas jóvenes que tomaron el relevo de la generación que gana el 18.
Que están en un momento de plenitud.
Y yo quiero ver el caso de Dembele.
A ver si vemos un Dembele parecido al de la temporada pasada del PSG.
En tercera posición.
Hemos situado.
Y aquí la cosa se pone seria.
Yo creo que este top 5 más o menos lo daba todo el mundo.
Las 5 secciones, digo.
No el orden.
Yo creo que es un top 5 en el que hay un escalón.
Por encima de las otras tres.
Pero si tú has el escalón entre el cuarto y el tercero.
Entre el segundo y el tercero.
Claro.
Es que yo lo sitúo entre el tercero y el cuarto.
¿Ah, sí?
Tú has hecho la del robot que diseña Lisa.
Sí.
El episodio de las vidas paralelas de los Simpsons.
Yo sitúo a Portugal tercera.
Vamos, lo situamos.
Y para mí Portugal.
Ahora mismo está un poquito más cerquita.
De las dos que nos quedan que de las dos por detrás.
Igual tiene su escalón propio.
Pero yo por eso sitúo a la diferencia ahí.
Yo le daría quizás un escalón.
Pero no le metería aún.
En el de las dos primeras que vamos a destacar ahora.
¿Ves potencial para que suba?
Porque hay muchos jugadores que están llegando muy muy bien.
Una base competitiva top.
El partido que nos planteó en la Nations.
Creo que fue soberbio.
Creo que ha crecido como selección.
En cuanto al propio juego ha evolucionado.
Porque con Roberto Martínez los primeros partidos fueron
de un ataque posicional bastante atascado.
Que le costaba bastante a Portugal.
Y creo que ha sido para preparar este continuo del partido ante Armenia.
Siendo la selección de Armenia.
Perfectamente hay que contextualizarlo.
Pero el ataque posicional me pareció bastante interesante.
Creo que es una selección que ha ganado recursos.
Y que como dices tiene a varios futbolistas que son de los mejores del mundo.
Y Vitinha parte muy atrás.
Desde muy abajo.
Y Joan de Villers muy arriba.
Están muy divididos.
Yo creo que tiene el aval de haber ganado la Nations.
De habernos complicado tanto.
De tener buenos resultados en esta fase de clasificación.
No es selección mundialista.
Claro, justo. Es que en fases finales no me lo he terminado a creer.
No terminé a cuajarme.
¿Dudas con la pareja de centales?
Sí.
Y mucha contribución de los jugadores que están en Arabia.
Todavía.
Lo hablábamos con Rubio en la primera hora.
A ver, a mí me convence bastante.
¿Tú qué le pondrías? ¿Más cerca de las dos que nos quedan?
O más cerca de las dos por detrás?
Más cerca de las dos de arriba.
Vale. Las dos de arriba.
Os imagináis cuáles son.
Son Argentina y España. España y Argentina.
¿El orden?
¿Lo hemos decidido de forma unánime?
¿Estamos de acuerdo a los cuatro?
Yo creo que ahora mismo no.
Yo ahora mismo me pido el cuerpo poner a otra por delante del lado.
No.
A mí me pide sorpaso también. Yo tengo dudas.
Lo podíais haber dicho cuando lo he preguntado.
Bueno, hombre.
Pero si lo bueno es debatirlo.
No, lo podéis decir.
Porque luego decimos que el powerrank tiene 4 y me encuentro que no.
Es debate.
En segunda posición.
¿Hemos colocado?
¿Hemos? En plural.
¿A España? ¿A la selección española?
No.
Yo creo que no encuentro motivo.
Y decimos ya quién es la primera
clasificada.
Nuestra primera favorita.
En este primer powerranking que es Argentina evidentemente.
Yo no veo motivo para bajar Argentina.
Veo motivos para subir a España.
Lo que no veo es motivo para bajar Argentina.
Me pasa como con el Liverpool y el Paris Saint Germain.
Yo diría que el máximo favorito es el Paris Saint Germain.
Pero el Liverpool ha crecido en la realidad.
Pero el Paris Saint Germain no veo...
No debería caer.
No.
España está en la segunda mejor racha de su historia.
Estamos viendo un fútbol
super atractivo.
Están vendiendo los resultados.
Campeona de la Eurocopa.
La Minyamal volando.
Una selección que en conjunto y en individual está destacando.
Y falta ese paso del Mundial.
Argentina ya la ha dado.
Tiene una selección que se experta.
O que ya ha sido capaz de tocar ese metal.
Yo sí que estoy viendo una selección de Argentina.
Igual en estos duelos contra España.
Alemania.
Alemania es un mal ejemplo. Francia.
Quiero verla.
Porque creo que ha bajado un poco respecto al 22.
Son dos selecciones que juegan de memoria.
Dos equipos.
Son dos equipazos con dos entrenadores.
Dos seleccionadores que están optimizando al máximo el talento.
La duda que tengo con Argentina
de cara al Mundial.
En Qatar es la cuestión emocional.
Es el tema emocional con Messi.
Otra vez.
Escaloni.
Yo te diría que ese es un check más que hecho.
Entre las Copas Américas.
El Mundial.
El otro día juega Messi su última parte en Argentina.
Y Escaloni vuelve a llorar.
Y se pasean.
Y yo creo que Argentina siempre va a tener ese punto emocional.
No es Europa.
Pero ese punto emocional
la has leído muy bien o muy mal.
El mismo está remando a favor.
En 2018...
Era una contra y ahora lo veo una virtud.
Fíjate la actitud de Messi con el himno.
Antes se tapaba. Incluso ponía la cara.
Y ahora lo canta.
Dicho lo cual, con España no hace falta motivos para poner la prima.
Hay de sobra.
Quizás el único punto es que hay que ver
cómo llegan Rodri y Carvajal.
Porque Rodri y Carvajal ya tienen el alta...
Como tú lo decías antes con Musiala.
El alta...
Médica.
Y para situar por delante de Argentina
necesito una versión de Rodri y Carvajal.
No sé si la de la Eurocopa.
Quizás la mejor temporada de los dos.
Uno a caballón de oro.
El otro cuarto o quinto.
No sé si eso.
Pero algo cercano a eso sí que necesitaría.
Por suerte.
Con un poco de suerte tendremos una finalísima.
Para poder dirimir esta cuestión.
A ti te parece tan importante esas dos piezas.
Quizás el movimiento lo está haciendo muy bien.
Y luego a mí el tema del lateral derecho
sí que me genera dudas.
En Argentina juega Nahuel Molina.
Y si no juega Molina juega Montiel.
Entonces, quiero decir...
A la hora de hacer la comparativa
puede influir.
Igual que estamos haciendo
esta clasificación ahora.
Y de aquí a 9 meses hay mil lesiones.
Y va a haber jugadores que van a ir con la lengua afuera.
Y por eso es tan complicado
hacer un pronóstico de equipos que juegan
tan poco juntos como es el fútbol de selecciones.
Y sobre todo con tanto tiempo por delante.
Por eso lo vamos a ir actualizando
en cada parón de selecciones.
Este es nuestro top 10
en el mes de septiembre
de cara al mundial 2026.
Argentina, España,
Portugal, Francia, Inglaterra,
Brasil, Países Bajos, Alemania,
Marruecos y Uruguay.
¡Gracias por ver!